- [Instructor] The four
corners of a rectangle
are located at the points
(11,7), (11,0), (2,0),
and (2,7).
Plot the four corners of the
rectangle on the coordinate
plane below, and they have these dots
and we can actually move these
around for the four corners
of our rectangle.
So let's look at this first point: (11,7).
Where will that go?
Well let's just remind
ourselves that the first
coordinate here, that is our x-coordinate.
That tells us how far we
move in the x-direction,
or how far we move to the right.
So our x-coordinate is 11, so we can say,
we can start at the origin
and move 11 to the right
and then our y-coordinate
is seven, which says hey
we need to move seven up from there.
So one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven.
So notice, 11, that's if
you were to just drop a line
straight down you would
hit the x-axis at 11
and the y-coordinate, if you
were to take a horizontal
line, if you were to go
straight to the left,
you get to y equals seven.
So this is the point (11,7).
Alright let's do the next one.
Then you have (11,0).
So let's line, lemme take
this point right over here.
So the x-coordinate is once
again 11, but the y-coordinate
is zero, which means we don't
move up at all in the ...
Or we don't move up at all.
One way to think about
it, start at the origin,
you move 11 to the right
and you move zero up.
So this is going to sit on
the x-axis right over there
(11,0).
Alright then we have (2,0).
So x-coordinate is two and
we don't move up at all.
So we're gonna sit on the x-axis.
We move two to the right and zero up,
or you can think of it zero
up and two to the right.
Then we have (2,7).
So x-coordinate is two,
but then we wanna move ...
X-coordinate is two, then
we wanna move seven up
to get right over there,
and so you can see
the corners of a rectangle right over here
and then they ask us, what is
the height of the rectangle?
Well let's see.
If we're going from y equals
zero to y equals seven,
so the height is seven.
You could even count it,
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven.
So the height of the rectangle is seven.
And then of course I can check my answer
and I got it right.